and the winner is le blé du blé en
région centre val de loire il y en a ici
dans le berry est là en beauce surtout
un boss il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup 5 millions de tonnes de blé par
an la région est la première productrice
de céréales en france et en europe avec
le blé est bien sûr mais aussi le maïs
et l'orge tous les champs de céréales de
la région soit un million trois cent
mille hectares recouvre la superficie
d'un territoire comme l'île de france
avec ses céréales sont fabriqués des
pattes du pain ou de la bière les
céréales sacré surtout de l'emploi
25000 personnes dans la région
travaillent dans cette filière comme
quoi le blé dans sa rappeur